did you know over 90% of mammals have
multiple sex partners makes you wonder
who are the biggest winners in the
animal kingdom bonobo chimpanzees these
guys have sex with multiple partners to
help ease social tensions within the
group they're also one of the few
animals who enjoy different sexual
positions part a topi antelopes female
Toki's are in heat only one day a year
thing is male Toki's are kind of
standoffish about sex which makes the
females much more aggressive than them
honeybee queens queen bees have
something called a mating flight this
consists of up to 40 worker bees whose
number-one job is to make sweet love to
the Queen it's not a bad gig except the
worker bees eventually die after mating
fire coloured beetles these don juan's
sometimes use toxic substances to get
their mates in the mood it's a chemical
called kantha renderman and it's
secreted from a gland in the male's head
gross North American else male Elks
always battle each other for female
affection and the winner of these
battles gets to breed with a herd of
females during a two-month long mating
season these herds can have up to 60
females in them get after it out the
elephant seals they have a thing called
beach masters where one large blubbery
male controls up to a hundred or more
female seals you can only become a beach
master after you beat the crap out of a
bunch of other male seals hey you got to
do what you got to do in the animal
kingdom play on playas you a lady in the
street but a freak in the forest